good evening and welcome to that pirates
today we'll be looking at a short called
always beware an anti-gay film that
deals with how the 1950s was anti-gay
enjoy poor Syd Davis he only produced
two films the Seventh Seal and this the
real dangerous book for boys throw some
of the best darn cross burnings this
side of the South okay
just scrolling down just just gonna stay
there okay that's fine let me move it up
I get wet okay Eddie jeans Danny I
thought I shot you nope I survived
okay then this man may seem like an
everyday man when really in fact he is
sorry we'll try to bring you something
juicier next week talk about silent
running I couldn't even hear the door
slam
I'm lieutenant William I looked at my
saucer attached to the juvenile division
i'm on my way to monroe junior high
school to talk to a group of young
people it's my story and I'm sticking to
it
had looked innocent enough doesn't it
lots of young people hitchhike seems
like a good way to get from one place to
another does sometimes there are dangers
involve let never meet the eye dangers
that lie in the twilight zone let's take
the case of Jimmy Barnes no Jimmy played
baseball all afternoon and he didn't
feel like walking home so he decided to
thumb a ride but that's not the only
thing he's going to film if you got that
then you're gay
is this is before the invention of
parenting he done it a hundred times
before he didn't think anything was
unusual when the driver struck up a
friendly conversation in fact he seemed
like a real nice guy he asked Jimmy if
he played baseball in the park often
jimmy told him they practiced three
times a week and played a rival group on
friday afternoon he then asked if he
liked gladiator too and it only seemed
minutes before they pulled up in front
of Jimmy's house where Jimmy's two
fathers were waiting
when Jimmy got out the stranger gave him
a friendly Pat I won't say where though
again if you got that you're gay then he
told him you'd see him again cuz he
always drove by the park on his way home
I love watching your ass when you walk
is a beautiful or what Jimmy spent many
an afternoon confusingly throwing a
glove around wishing he had friends sure
enough the following day when jimmy
finished playing ball well the man was
there waiting hi damn I've never been in
a convertible before really well I guess
you're about ready then aren't you let
it be known that gay men have a horrible
tendency of remaining feckless they
stopped at a drive-in a stranger treated
him to a cook during their conversation
he told several off-color jokes but
Jimmy had heard others before and well
it made him feel big to so easily win
the confidence of an older person you're
the one about the black Jewish female
Polack who wasn't a human being it's the
1950s does every joke I hear yes little
do you know that gays and pedophiles are
the exact same thing the following
saturday they went fishing together by
now they were using first names ralph
said it was more friendly
thanks a lot mr. Gaylord weeds call me
flaming you like popsicles
Jimmy hadn't enjoyed himself so much in
a long time little did he know that the
best was yet to come
then during lunch ralf showed him some
pornographic pictures Wow Jimmy knew he
shouldn't be interested but well he was
curious but Jimmy didn't know was that
ralph was sick the sickness that was not
visible like smallpox or dark skin less
dangerous and contagious a sickness of
the mind you see ralf was a homosexual a
person who demands an intimate
relationship with members of their own
sex we can't stop here this is Becca
tree but by now jimmy felt a fondness
for ralph and they continued to go
places together ralf was generous and
took jimmy many interesting places and
did many nice things for him he took it
to the most horrible hangouts like the
manicures and Mamma Mia
he bought presents and even gave him
money but payments were expected in
return oh you see Jimmy hadn't
recognized Ralph's approach soon enough
when ralf first step jimmy to go fishing
alone he should have discussed it with
his parents or teacher wealth now uses
his telepathic gay power is to keep
Jimmy from leaving finally jimmy told
his parents and they reported it to the
juvenile authorities ralph was arrested
and jimmy was released on probation and
the custody of his parents don't worry
we watch the game but all homosexuals
are not passive some resort to violence
is in the case of mike merritt mike
merritt the very name invites
douchebaggery
in the heat of competition no one
noticed the man who sat and watched I
think that's the coach and when the game
broke up and the others left mike
decided to stay and practice a little
longer wait is mike the kid or the
predator in what specific movie I can't
judge both of them unfairly
the stranger joined him he was friendly
well it was better than playing alone
it just got done eating kittens and
rubbing himself in chicken blood but
after a few shots mike realized he had
already overstayed his time and
suggested he better leave the stranger
told him if he'd like to stay longer
he'd be glad to drive him home and they
finished sounded great to mike chance to
play longer and get a ride home too of
course he had no idea that Chris
Hanson's Dateline special was just a
phone call away I play in my talks
because I went to the Tommy was so
school of sports haha
din sonic says tell me something about
this when they finish the stranger told
him and make a fine player someday if he
got lots of practice despite his wife
did some pan Ying ship the praised the
friendly attitude dispelled any
misgivings Mike might have had about
going with a stranger he probably never
realized until too late that he was
riding in the shadow of death on a car
but sometime that evening mike merritt
traded his life for a newspaper headline
news flesh gays pedophiles and the devil
are all the same
as danny and jerry got the papers ready
for jerry afternoon delivery they only
casually noticed the two boys that raced
by in the afternoon traffic that's
casual and they didn't pay much
attention to the car that grew up
shortly afterwards until a man called
them over why would he call them that
either you ever been in a Turkish prison
and two boys been buying bicycles the
boys nodded they had could they
recognize him if they saw them again
well then he guessed he could and
hopping the man said those are stolen
bikes dananananana dumbest jerry watched
he been told many times if a friend got
in a car with a stranger to write down
the license number
I tell not to get in the car apply but
well fortunately he marked it down Jerry
knew something what's wrong with Denny
called the next day and said he want to
go floor shopping and watch Gilmore
Girls when he delivered a paper to
Denny's house he asked his mother if
they caught the boys that has stolen the
bicycle detect any hadn't returned so he
told her the story and gave her the
paper with the license number well why
didn't he hitchhike like usual that's
the safer method
being a careful parent she decided to
call the police
Jerry supplied the necessary information
and the strangers car was quickly
spotted was a good example of how
important it is to always get the
license number and description of any
stranger who takes a young person off
alone no matter what they tell you
good thing he happened to be driving to
that dead-end for no apparent reason
yeah I can see why they deleted this
from Leave It to Beaver public restrooms
can often be a hangout for the
homosexual there's a good start on a
story notice the man who had been in the
restroom when they change where they
take the shortcut under the pier but the
others preferred to take the more
traveled way home oh it's better than
waiting for that kid from my space
always keep in mind the homosexuals feet
often have musical accompaniment
I can hear your musically Baldus
footsteps
when bobby recognized the stranger is
the man in the restroom the shortcut
under the fear didn't seem like a good
idea at all
I'm gonna take the shortcut through the
venomous snake bit I'll look at you next
time bubby next time
after all it's more fun to stay with
your friends anyway Bobby had made a
wise decision it may have saved his life
and even better kept it straight the
decision is always you're a troll or
elles future may depend on making the
right one so no matter where you meet a
stranger be careful if they are to
friendly if they try to win your
confidence too quickly and if they
become overly personal one never knows
when the homosexual is about he may
appear normal and it may be too late
when you discover he is mentally ill so
keep with your group and don't go off
alone with strangers unless you have the
permission of your parent or teacher now
if you'll excuse me I have to wet myself
for thinking about an episode of bosom
buddies remember prejudice is wrong
unless it's against the right people you
should never question Authority paranoia
is your friend and anything different is
evil good night and enjoy fearing this
world though you'll never understand why